welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud I'm Vinny one Zukowski
and today we're gonna talk about GCP 4G
suite users we're hosting these live
webinars every Tuesday throughout the
talk you can enter questions in the
platform below
and Googlers would be standing by to
answer at the end of the talk we're
gonna choose some of your questions to
answer during live Q&A with that said
let's get started with the presentation
as I mentioned my name is Vincent Lee
Joukowsky and I'm a cloud sales manager
I've been working for the past seven
years with helping customers or clients
onboard to various cloud platforms hey
guys my name is Nick pan I'm a cloud
customer engineer that works on the
Google cloud team I've been working with
a lot of customers as well as business
leaders and developers undetermined the
best way to host application on Google
cloud super excited be r-j and talk to
you about how Google cloud to empower
your G suite users so in terms of you
know thematically what we hope to do is
is talk a little bit about how we're
engaging with customers we're going to
do a couple demos and we're also going
to talk about some case studies and some
differentiate errs and how customers are
actually using Google technology to
innovate
purging various aspects of google cloud
to meet you where you're at and help you
innovate it doesn't mean if the lift and
shift or move your entire infrastructure
even though that's way working some of
our customers but it's leveraging things
like api's it's bridging some of our
platform services and a lot of it how
can we meet you where you're at and be
able to provide value so when we talked
about Google cloud platform one of the
most important things to talk about is
the scale we actually bring and and one
of the things that demonstrates scale is
is you're already working with Google in
some of the G suite platform services we
provide and a thing to note and and
those same services or the same scale as
available for you to build on top of is
powering over seven products that have
over a hundred of 1 billion users each
so in sense of how we're making
investments in the platform over the
past 3 years we've invested not only
capital but we have partner advancements
we have new region standing up and we
have innovations in terms of creating
commercialized versions of Google tech
that has made us successful so when we
talked about it's not just spinning
discs it's whether you want to leverage
us for an API to build a in a creative
value to your current environment or
whether it's building that globally
distributed application we're engaged in
customers on a lot of different levels
so when we talked about Google Cloud as
a whole there are a lot of different
ways of working with customers we're
going to talk about GCP today but all of
you on the live broadcast are very
familiar with G suite services some of
those same capabilities in terms of
building globally distributed storage
systems and collaboration those
capabilities are are available for you
to integrate into your applications
what GCP as a whole has a very deep and
broad capability of portfolio and we're
certainly engaged in customers and
anything from moving entire data centers
or just providing access to our API so
they can build those into their existing
applications and services so when we
take a high-level look at you know just
the tiers of services are offering many
people
may not be aware but when he comes to
business platforms such as Apogee or
Orbitz era or leveraging some of our AP
is what we've been leaning into or or
making sure that we make available is
the ability for customers not to have to
move any of their infrastructure how can
we create an environment that's going to
provide value Apogee managing or
monetizing your API business orbit error
providing some some SAS platform
offerings to you leveraging our API is
to actually integrate into your existing
applications the other thing we have
been seeing in the marketplace or or
with our customers is customers want a
variety of offerings anything from
analytics and machine learning which is
certainly a an area that can stand alone
but they also want to build and deploy
applications and not have to worry about
that undifferentiated heavy lifting of
managing infrastructure so things like
App Engine and compute and container
engine areas where you can deploy and
build applications on a global scale
without having to manage the base
storage and VMs with that said we're
also going to talk about some of the
core infrastructure storage and
networking components that certainly are
interesting and we believe provides some
differentiators again building global
infrastructure or the business value so
right now what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
have Nick talk about security networking
and infrastructure and talk a little bit
about some of the core differentiators
that we have on our on our base platform
hey Vinnie thanks so much for that
overview let's take a little bit deeper
into things that were surround security
networking and infrastructure on Google
cloud and we'll hopefully uncover some
of the secret sauce that really makes
Google cloud a very novel platform to
hozier infrastructure on we believe that
we have an excellence in raw bility we
have unparalleled speed and scalability
2018 for a total of 15 region globally
and we have four more that are being
announced in 2018 across the board we
believe that we have save the our
infrastructure and unparalleled
performance and we'll allude to this in
the further slides on this presentation
so digging deep into what we often tell
us
summers in the industry we often hear
users saying that they want to lift and
shift to the cloud but at Google we
actually use the term lift and improve
the reason why I want to say lift and
improve is because as you start using
these cloud native technologies I use as
you start embracing some of these
higher-level services and ap is you're
actually able to improve your overall
business model and accelerate your
business and transform your IT
department we have one really awesome
feature in orders live migration and
that's the ability to basically move
virtual machines from one underlying
host to another underlying host so to
make from a live migration that it seems
like an interesting feature but how
operationally is that really going to
change the way I'm doing business how is
that going to impact our customers to
improve upon what they were doing well
that's a really great question in terms
of the starter year I'm sure many of you
in the audience have heard of the CPU
vulnerabilities that occur in January
meltdown inspector these were CPU
vulnerabilities where there was a very
high severity and a very neat very
business critical need to patch your
CPUs and make sure that we reduce the
risk of the of those security as much as
possible with live migration Google
cloud was actually able to patch all of
our underlying fleet which out are cut
without our customers actually noticing
any sort of downtime or patching done to
those instances so as you start using
Google cloud technology you inherit all
these benefits and employ a very secure
security posture also we have a very
customer friendly pricing model so we
have features such as sustained use
discounts which are automatic discounts
on our virtual machines as you use them
and generally we see customers who are
using a Google cloud platform to save
around 30 percent on virtual machines a
month just based on by using those
automatic sustained use discounts we
also have the idea of custom machine
types which are the ability to fine-tune
your configuration other virtual
machines in terms of number of CPUs as
well as gigabytes of RAM in order to
really cater your machine shapes to meet
the needs of your applications so Nick
that's interesting news from a more
flexible business on model what is
actually mean for you know a retail
customer or somebody
media and how sustained use Dish
discounts and custom machine types can
impact their business operations and
affect their bottom line so in terms of
in industries when you think about
things like using cloud for burst
capacity oftentimes you're not actually
committing to a particular instance type
or a reservation in terms of pools of
compute with that you're actually able
to have sustained use discounts
automatically applied to that burst
capacity and have real time discounts
based off of those fluctuations of usage
for your applications additionally for
customers who are looking to lift and
improve not lift and shift we actually
see them not understanding really how
the cloud works yet but they're able to
benefit from sustained usage discounts
because they're not having to commit to
anything at that point and they're just
inheriting that sustained use discount
as they ramp up so overall increasing
agility having a more customer friendly
business model and ensuring that we're
giving all the controls to the customer
to make sure you're making the right
choices in terms of price as well as
performance so basically true cloud
economics and no guesswork and how to
get discounting exactly and we believe
that the bread-and-butter of Google
cloud that makes us so powerful is our
underlying global infrastructure if you
look at this slide we could see that
this is our global footprint as I said
before 15 regions we offer we maintain
one of the largest backbones on the
internet currently statistics show from
third parties that we probably have
around 30 percent of the world's
Internet traffic passed through our
backbone on any given day and what this
empowers you as a developer or you as a
business leader is being able to harness
this network to host your applications
either closer to your users or to reduce
latency as well as the overall hops that
it takes to reach your users as well as
have system-to-system traffic so very
powerful for increasing that network
throughput in that network bandwidth and
we really believe Google Cloud as a
place to build multi-regional globally
distributed systems on the cloud and
this really shows you where the rubber
meets the road where it actually shows
you instances doing network diagnostic
tests between two regions so I went
ahead and spun up a virtual machine in
Oregon as well as a virtual machine in
Japan
ended up paying as well as a trace route
across bidirectionally from those
instances if you could see on the bottom
there's actually only one hop that it
traverses when it goes between our VMs
and the reasons for that is because we
operate our network backbone and we're
able to hold on to that traffic for
majority of the route and ensure that
you have a secure consistent as well as
a reliable route as you pass through the
internet on our backbone so Nick what
I'm saying is whether or not you are
building an isolated application in one
of our regions or building a distributed
application in multiple regions you're
going to benefit from staying on our
backbone from a security and a
consistent performance from a network
standpoint
exactly so we don't have to actually
push traffic to a transit ISP or transit
provider we operate our backbone are
able to ensure that performance and
along with all this we believe that we
very very much excel in security across
the board at Google cloud so we employ a
defense in depth at scale by default
posture so from the hardware level in
terms of the actual infrastructure to
the actual higher levels which are
things like operational end device
security we ensure that we have all
those check boxes checked and we're
making sure that you embrace that
security model that we bring to the
table one of the differential at Google
cloud is that we ensure that data things
like pushing objects to object storage
and things of that sort
are all encrypted by default we want to
make sure that your data is secure and
we want to make sure that we're setting
you guys up for success when you
leverage our tools as well as our
products another thing is that we
actually manufacture a lot of our
hardware and a lot of it is
purpose-built for our needs and this
leads to better performance as well as
reducing the chance of vendor in the
middle of risks when you're actually
procuring peripherals from other vendors
so Nick a couple things I see from that
because we get a scripture all the time
so certainly on top of Google since
everything's encrypted at fault it's not
left up up to the operator so you're
ensuring that all of your data is
encrypted all the time so from an
operation standpoint is an efficiency
there but I also see from a performance
standpoint if you're taking a look at a
VM certainly encryption is overhead to
infrastructure if that's already baked
into our infrastructure
inherent value and cost associated with
that is already included so you have
security operations and in cost
efficiencies what if somebody wants to
bring in their own keys and wants to
manage keys on top of that encryption
what do we do then so we have offerings
that allow customers to bring their own
keys so they're called customer manage
keys they integrate with many our
services and we also have a key
management service for if you want to
have an actual managed kms that could do
things like rotate keys set a key wrote
key expiration policy and things of that
sort and in terms of certifications for
third party audits as well as
accreditations we are checked off across
the board these are just to name a few
we have a page on our website cloud
google.com slash security that breaks
down all these accreditation as well as
different white papers that really drill
home what happens under the hood at
Google to ensure that our platform is
safe and secure
excellent so certainly all that's good
information but you know I think when it
comes down to it it's it's all about our
customers and the impression that they
get in working with Google and also
leveraging our technology and the set of
us telling the story it's it's always
good to take a look at what what some of
the people who have decided to to move
onto GCP and leverage our services are
saying so Etsy is actually a good
example of somebody who's going through
a transformation and trying to
concentrate on you know providing value
to their customers and not have to worry
about managing spinning spinning discs
or data centers so if you take a look at
um you know what Mike Fisher Etsy's CTO
has said about working with Google it
wasn't just about the technology it
wasn't just about the machine learning
it results about working with Google
engineers directly as well as our
professional services as well as our our
engagement team so there are a lot of
factors that come into selecting the
right provider and I think if you
actually take a look at what mike has
done in terms of doing product selection
there's a link that will provide there's
really a comprehensive look is - it's
not just about what technology is
available today and capabilities but
it's also looking about how are you
looking to grow in the future both
regionally as well as globally so you
know a lot of people out there are
listening and certainly Etsy as a law
environment but certainly I wouldn't
expect everybody ready to just drop
their entire data center or move from
move from existing cloud right at us if
somebody wanted to get started with a
simple one VM move how can we help them
do that is there something we can kind
of demonstrate for them yeah so I put
together a demo where bassy goes through
one of our tools are baked into our
platform we built this in partnership
with cloud under and it's basically a
built-in via import that allows you to
move a virtual machine from other
on-premises or another cloud into Google
cloud platform completely managed so if
you see in this demo we're walking
through kind of what the overall
workflow looks like but high-level what
it does as you go through installation
of agents on the VM that you're trying
to migrate as well as the the target VM
that's within Google cloud platform you
select like a VM shape or a
configuration for that virtual machine
and then the actual agent begins a
continuous replication between that
source and that target once replication
is finished you have that target
instance that is a complete mirror of
your source that's either on-premise or
another cloud and you could easily
provide some testing and then do a cut
over and what this allows you to do is
have a completely managed solution that
allows you to move your virtual machines
from another area into the cloud and
then the kicker is that it's completely
free so we cover all the costs and it's
provided to you as an added service to
our Google compute engine service which
is our virtual machines or
infrastructure as a service tool great
so that's interesting because it looks
like we're using a partner and a partner
technology on on how to actually get
started what's interesting about that is
it's it's a tool in a service that's
already built in you know and and it's
some additional value that we're
actually providing how do you get out
yep all right so I guess the the next
thing that we want to talk about is some
additional customer examples so if you
take a look at folks at and moving to us
we talked about Etsy one of the things
that we do want to we do want to talk
about is um is quantconnect who's
another great example of somebody levar
Google cloud platform they started out
as a G suite user they actually were
leveraging another cloud provider and
what they were looking for was better
efficiency better reliability as well as
some some overall business value or cost
savings and if you take a look at the
number of products they're using they
definitely lean in a lot using container
engine as well as cloud sequel so
they're really taking advantage of not
only the platform services but some of
the inherent business value the nice
part about this use case is they were
able to get better reliability and also
drive some some significant value from a
business value cost savings so
reliability as well as remaining and
keeping a flat cost while increasing
their business by 6x pretty pretty
impressive at the beginning of the
presentation or the conversation we
talked about our service strategy so
it's not just about spinning disk it's
not just about leveraging our API is but
certainly services is one of the areas
where a lot of folks are leaning in and
and supporting you know their cloud
strategy what's interesting about this
is Google actually start out in the the
service space with our App Engine
product and Nick Rockwell who's who's
actually a very interesting person in
the cloud industry is actually
leveraging a multi cloud strategy and
where he's leaning to Google cloud is is
in the service area where he's
leveraging App Engine 2 and other
service capabilities to actually
accelerate and not worry about managing
spinning disk or object storage he's
definitely leaning into supporting the
overall value of getting applications
out to customers faster so we've covered
a lot of technology 1/3 a lot of terms
that you folks we know that a lot of you
guys are using GCP or g suite
administrators and here's a simple use
case for how you could use some of these
google cloud technologies to improve
your business within G suite there's a
lot of logs or output to your G suite
administrator dashboard as well as a lot
of audit trails they could use to draw
meaningful insights for your business
you could easily take that data and move
it into our data warehouse known as
bigquery and draw a meaningful
dashboards using a tool known as data
studio so you see on this slide there's
this G suite insights page
and be able to easily create these nice
dashboards that allow you to look at
things like how are my Doc's usage
across my organization
how is my collaboration how many hours
of WebEx how many hours of GBC how we
had throughout the presentation or
throughout our organization so being
able to easily determine a lot of
awesome insights from using these tools
is what drives value to you as a
customer so I'm saying building a single
pane of glass whether it's G suite log
information or information from things
like google analytics or double-click
there are a lot of use cases where
customers are building a single pane of
glass using using bigquery as that
engine awesome yep and there's a lot of
integrations between our different
services so this is a quick demo that I
that I created that allowed you to be
able to query sheets from your big query
engine and we're gonna walk through this
real quick so to access the console you
go ahead and go to console Google the
console cloud google.com and from there
you're able to actually go ahead and use
bigquery as your execution engine to
query data sets within sheets so within
here you could see that you could pull a
Google Drive file which could be a sheet
that's specified in our my your
particular drive and then from there
this particular demo we're going to go
ahead and analyze Black Friday market
sales data within our sheet so here you
can see that there's things like the
items that were sold the cost of those
particular items as well as meaningful
information for this particular
spreadsheet you can easily pull us into
bigquery and then run queries against it
using standard sequel syntax and what is
great about this is you could basically
use bigquery to query very very large
data sets that might be larger than
what's available in sheets and I move
forwards from there and provide
accessibility to this tool with your
data analysts by just creating users and
inviting them to your project so so just
as an end user what it looks like to me
is we're turbocharging sheets to kind of
extend it into tremendous scale and
capabilities to get information in and
out whether it's leveraging sheets as
that
data source or potentially exporting
data from this petabyte scale engine
exactly so one of the ways that um you
know we talked about earlier is
leveraging Google api's how can how can
our customers work with us without
changing any of the underlying
infrastructure and one of the things
that customers are working with us on is
certainly from a bigquery standpoint or
data analytics but the other area is
machine learning machine learning is
certainly a topic or an area that that
Google has been leveraging within a
whole array of products you need to take
a look at all the products we've got
displayed we've been incorporating
machine learning capabilities and
features that you might be familiar with
things like data loss prevention in G
suite in the Enterprise version things
like in photos where you can do
categorize by by somebody's somebody's
face or or the the actual event that's
happening things like in translate we're
actually using advanced machine learning
techniques to get better and better
translation capabilities a lot of these
services or api's are now available for
you and nice part about it is you don't
need to change where your infrastructure
is it can provide immediate value one of
the things we talked to customers on
base in their journey is they might have
moved to a secondary reviser
they might be on Prem they might not be
ready to move but if we can bring value
now it's an important part of that
leveraging Google tech and leveraging
the US for their um their technology or
their innovation journey so one of the
great examples of to do a better
correlation or matching for their
recruitment efforts what they're able to
get is significant improvements in the
click throughs on the career sites based
on the searches people are doing as well
as the quality of the applications so we
have a number of folks whether it's a
platform service provider or an
enterprise customer who are just using
something as simple as our jobs API to
help them innovate or help them do
things differently another great example
of an
and leaning to customers to help them
categorize and drive additional revenues
is is Hearst Hearst has been leveraging
our natural language processing API
which allows them to get better
contextual awareness on you know what
conversations are being have what what
is of interest to their customers so
we've been able imbibe their the natural
language processing API as well as
leaning into two engines like bigquery
on all what it would allows them to do
is has personalized user experiences and
and and hopefully drive additional
revenue in a long time so it's certainly
driving business value as well as
innovation so have any in terms of
across the publishing space are there
other machine learning API is that you
see customers you often using for
publishing sure that that's a that's a
great question a lot of customers you
know on a you know on the first use case
or leveraging our vision API or our
video API for doing dynamic meta tagging
so there are a lot of ways that we can
certainly start again something as
simple as an API and then often you know
as we as we progress with the customer
we might get into different discussions
and and you know even get into things
like Apogee or even infrastructure place
so it's really about like where can we
help customers now and provide value
immediately so in terms of getting
started with GCP there are a lot of ways
you can get started with us we certainly
are working with people in many areas of
their cloud or technology journey for
innovation or just learning analytics
and big data consolidating all the
analytics so then you can potentially
apply machine learning capabilities on
top of it or to just get that single
pane of glass that we talked about from
a from a advertising single pane glass
or just you know some log files so in my
opinion the easiest way to get started
with Google Cloud if you're just you're
trying to start to use it as a platform
is to have a hobby project you have a
blog try to create that blog and Google
compute engine and try to scale that out
as you need as traffic grows but across
the board is very easy to get started
test dev we're they using us for per
data archiving or even HPC workloads
which would
very bursty in nature you know the speed
of performance that global networking
that we talked about the global scale
and also the fact that from a business
value standpoint you're achieving those
usage-based or those automatic
discounting constructs to truly make it
cloudy or have cloud economics as
opposed to you know restricting people
based on their ability to run things
24/7 which is really not a cloud model
so resources so we'd love if everybody
on this call reaches out and connects
with us and we can actually have
discussions with with everybody on the
line right now everybody on the webcast
the best way to get in touch with your
Google cloud technical resources or
cloud sales managers is to just go to
cloud google.com slash contact fill out
a form we'll reach you out if you're
already in touch with us we'd love to
have some deeper conversations with you
another great resource if you don't want
to reach out to us but you want to keep
up to date with what's going on with the
cloud platform and all the new
innovations or the the new regions is to
apply or register for our newsletter a
really great way to keep up to date with
all the new things or even the the the
new platforms or the use cases that
we're actually coming out from
architectural recommendations from a
training standpoint there are a lot of
ways that customers can directly get
training or learn about our platform
there's quick labs which are you know
interactive labs that will showcase how
to do anything from standing up a vm all
the way down to machine learning and
leveraging bigquery
there's on-demand training or online
training courses with Coursera that's
more of a formalized training course as
a lab we also have formalized classroom
training that you can actually sign up
for if you go to cloud.google.com slash
training but you can also reach out to
your cloud account executive and we can
certainly work with you to tell or
classes that might fit more into your
your needs so we definitely want to work
with you the last thing that I actually
want to talk about is from from an
advancement or engaging with Google
there's a rich ecosystem
of partner capabilities whether we have
systems integrators large and small
global and scale or regional and agile
with specialties there are a lot of ways
that we've been growing your ecosystem
and you can work with Google partners
directly Google professional services
we'd love to hear from you and we'd love
to get a little bit more on how we can
help you implement Google technology so
in terms of getting started today we
appreciate your time we'll be back in
under a minute once we had a chance to
review some of the questions that you've
been asking hopefully over the last
thirty minutes we'll select a few
questions and we'll come back and we'll
we'll hopefully give you some some good
answers thank you Thanks
you
hi welcome back again Vinnie ones are
Kowski nick pan we've got five questions
that were asked to the asked from the
audience and we're going to do our best
to answer them there they're diverse in
nature but we'll kind of start from the
bottom up instead of top down and and
the first question is specifically on
health care industry and building HIPAA
compliant applications on top of GCP so
Google Cloud Storage is is is one of the
services that's actually built to be
HIPAA compliant but in general as an
overview absolutely Google you can build
and deploy globally distributed or
regionally distributed HIPAA compliant
applications in fact we talked about our
service capabilities and recently I
think about a week ago we announced that
app engine is now capable of providing
HIPAA compliant applications so you can
do anything from store the content on
Google Cloud Storage you can build
applications from the ground up using
our virtual machines or you can build
full service applications on top of that
better and to take this a step further
for customers who are handling very
sensitive data we have API such as the
data loss prevention API which is
actually baked into G suite as well so
being able to see or analyze a block of
text and we're saying if there's things
in there that are sensitive in nature
things like social security numbers
things like user identities or things
that fall in the umbrella of PII great
so the next question is is about explain
the low latency options when we have
customers that operate in multi regions
how decide where to put and cost
estimates it's actually a pretty big
question and I think we'd have to dig
into the specific use case but let's
talk about a couple scenarios I think
you know we covered a lot of them and
and one of the the benefits was our
global distributed network but what we
didn't really drill into is some of the
services that we've built that take
advantage of that network that can be
built to potentially distribute your
application things like our goo
Google cloud storage you have the option
on top of GCP to build in a regional
bucket if you so choose but what you can
also do is you can build object storage
to do distribution within a continent so
you can actually have a distributed
workload I actually have one customer
there a media company and they do a lot
of transcoding and one of the things
that they need to do is they need to
select infrastructure in a very bursty
nature the fact that they're able to
take advantage of our globally
distributed object storage allows them
to pull and spin up transcoding
resources potentially in the SPOC market
from any of our regions around the
United States that doesn't limit them
from staying isolated within a region
since they're talking about video files
once they transcode they drop it in
object storage it's read after write
consistency and read after list
consistency on a continent basis so
again distributed compute resources from
a where do I grab the VM from but the
fact that we're actually distributing
the object storage is really a value
that if you look at other providers in
some case you should have to add tiers
or implement additional layers of
services in order to accomplish the same
thing I totally agree this is a very
dimensional question so I kind of like
in the end of the presentation you have
a sales rep you have a customer engineer
so if you are looking to architect
multi-regional deployments on Google
cloud platform definitely use those
channels of engagement with the Google
cloud team to ensure that you're doing
this the right way we have any white
papers that walk over how to actually
design this from the engineering
standpoint and also many services that
video Bluetooth that can make sure that
we drive costs down I would design this
in an optimal fashion for your team so
the next question is we talked about
it's not about spinning discs it's about
helping customers innovate using Google
tacking and everybody on online is using
G suite to innovate you're gonna hear in
a little bit about how you can extend
that use Chambord to create a better
meeting experience so we're going to
talk about that but in terms of not just
spinning discs on top of us I'd be
remiss not to mention especially based
on the first coin
within the healthcare space Google is
uniquely positioned to not only allow
you to build your HIPAA compliant
workloads in a region or distributed
across region but gaining access to that
HIPAA compliant data managing that end
user experiencing using Chrome is an
operating system whether it's a kiosk
whether it's a tablet whether it's a
Chromebook to ensure that you have end
and HIPAA compliance and control it's
not just about what's in the back end or
data center from a security but it's how
is that data being being entered and
managed on those endpoints so we're
Aneke uniquely positioned to do that and
we actually have quite a few use cases
we're in healthcare chrome and G suite
and a lot of other capabilities are
marrying well to our back-end
infrastructure yeah on the ball yeah
right so I guess the next question is
about machine learning maybe I'll let
MIT kind of pick this one is is how are
we working with customers to implement
and take advantage of you know machine
learning which which which Google
certainly has been leaning into from
from tensorflow in our platform what are
ways we're doing so across the board we
believe that we have a leadership in
machine learning I'm at Google cloud we
have these pre trained machine learning
api's which allow you to easily do tasks
such as use computer vision to extract
meaningful information from images or
using our video intelligence API to be
able to pull out metadata or meaningful
information from videos that customers
are trying to ingest into some sort of
object storage we also release a new
service known as Auto ml which is riding
off of the message from our CEO sundar
which is dude which is to democratize AI
for the general public and what
democratized AI means is the fact that
there's not as many data scientists as
our developers in the world so be able
to empower developers with these machine
learning models that we've trained
in-house at Google based off of running
these datasets through the datasets that
we have running our production systems
and empowering these developers with
these blackbox api's that again that
they can then feed things into to be
able to drive meaningful insights
on the auto ml side we're basically
baking it so that you could actually
ingest and tweak these particular models
to meet more so to your data sets and go
through it easy GUI to be able to tray
these models to meet your tailored data
sets so to take this a step further what
that means is that the vision API might
be able to recognize that this image is
a dog or a cat but then if you were to
train this on a more deeper data set
which is something that you as a
customer brings to the table you'll be
able to actually recognize like the
species of the dog so baby be able to
say this is not just a dog but a golden
retriever or this is not just a dog
there's a poodle so across the board
doing a lot of things in the Xin
learning space so why here customization
without a lot of the overhead that often
comes with customization that's super
exciting and personally I'm I'm super
jazzed about Auto ml just based on
question of machine learning and leaning
in with Google sir
lots of customers and and easy use cases
to get started started on both the last
part is we talked about API service
technology and infrastructure services
what are my options for a multi-vendor
environment so you know that's that's
certainly in a cloud journey people are
saying they're all in an one but a lot
of folks are talking about you know how
can I use the right platform threat
workload how can I take advantage of you
know the cloud marketplace a lot of
vendors in it so what are we doing there
yeah so I mean in terms of Oberto Oberto
we have a cloud marketplace where you
can actually leverage the tool to be
able to organize with different vendors
and software in terms of having a multi
vendor approach we're actually able to
peel off some of the services and tools
to be able to leverage some of our
higher level services so it's something
really key to drilling on is that we
have a lot of services at Google cloud
but it's a lot card so you could use
services as you need so if you're trying
to use something for data analytics if
you want a very powerful sequel
execution engine you could go ahead and
just use bigquery to analyze your data
sets if you're looking just have like a
website hosted within the cloud you
could choose to use Google compute
engine to host your virtual machines
there's a lot of really interesting
things you could do with Google cloud
platform and understand how all these
pieces fit into overall picture that's
what really drives value for you as a
user so you know what gets me excited
about you know multi multi vendor
environment I think the with the
proliferation of of containers and
kubernetes as the default scheduler I
think the fact that it was part of
Google's sponsorship of that program to
actually bring that to bear is certainly
something that that's exciting to me as
well as tensorflow on some of the other
open source programming that will allow
people to build in the multi clad so we
really appreciate everybody's time
that's all the time we have for today
thanks for tuning in to cloud on air
we're glad you joined us we're running
these webinars every Tuesday stay tuned
and for the next one which is going to
be integrated or
or better meetings leveraging some of
our jam board technology alright thank
you so much
you